Saying that a story has a beginning, a
middle, and an end is a useless piece of
information that does nothing to
describe a story. And more importantly,
it does nothing to help you tell a
story.
When people tell you that stories have
beginnings, middles, and endings, it is
some of the worst possible advice they
can give you if you're hoping to tell
better stories. Let me tell you why.
The reason why this is terrible advice
is because everything in the world has a
beginning, middle, and end. This
morning, I got dressed. It had a
beginning, a middle, and an end. I
started with my underwear, that was the
beginning. Then I put on a shirt and a
pair of pants, that was the middle. And
then shoes and socks, that was the end.
Does it help people get dressed to know
it has a beginning, a middle, and an
end? No, it doesn't help in any way
whatsoever. Everything has a beginning,
a middle, and an end. A Snickers bar has
a beginning, a middle, and an end. It
has a beginning, I opened it up.
I take a bite.
Uh, it's okay. Not the best Snickers bar
in the world. Stories should have great
beginnings, better than this one, by the
way. Eventually, I would get to the
middle.
The middle is no good, either. And then
eventually, I would get to the end.
The end. Oh, I got a really bad Snickers
bar. Most are good. I think it's cuz
it's so cold.
>> I think it's probably cuz I got it at
the gas station. That doesn't help you
make a Snickers bar. Doesn't help you
even understand what a Snickers bar is.
Everything has a beginning, a middle,
and an end. My life, as much as I don't
want to admit to it, has a beginning, a
middle, and an end. I was born, I don't
remember it, but I was born, and that
was the beginning. I'm now somewhere in
the middle, and then theoretically,
hopefully not, but possibly so, someday
there will be an end. That doesn't
define a life. That doesn't even help
you understand how to live a life.
Saying that a story has a beginning, a
middle, and an end is a useless piece of
information that does nothing to
describe a story. And more importantly,
it does nothing to help you tell a
story.
A story is not a beginning, a middle,
and an end. A story is a singular moment
in your life in which something changed.
You thought about the world in a
different way, you thought about
yourself in a different way, you changed
fundamentally as a human being. A
singular moment in time that is wrapped
around the context that brings that
singular moment to the greatest clarity
possible.
One moment in time, what I call a
five-second moment, cuz these changes
happen instantaneously, a five-second
moment with the context wrapped around
it to make that five-second moment as
clear as possible to the audience you're
speaking to. That is what a story is. A
singular moment in time where something
changed about you or your perception of
the world, and the context that you wrap
around that moment to bring it to the
greatest clarity possible to your
audience. And that is every single movie
you've ever seen, every TV show you've
ever watched, every book you've ever
read, any play or musical you've seen on
the stage, and any story that I have
ever told. If it doesn't have a
five-second moment of transformation,
it's not bad, it's just called an
anecdote. It's just a moment in time
that is amusing and silly and
delightful, but doesn't have the
stickiness, the unforgettableness, the
staying power, the connectiveness, the
relatability of an actual story. They're
not bad, you just have to understand
they don't have the power of an actual
story. So, when you're thinking about
storytelling, and you're thinking about
to craft a story, I'm going to produce a
great story for the screen or the stage,
or maybe just on my first date, the last
thing you should think about, the very,
very last thing you should think about
is it needs a beginning, a middle, and
an end. Because no matter what you say,
no matter what the length of the thing
you say is, it will always inherently
have a beginning, a middle, and an end.
But does that help you in any way? It
doesn't. Everything has a beginning, a
middle, and an end. So, it is stupid,
meaningless advice for crafting better
stories. Instead, find a moment. Find a
moment that means something to you in
this world. Wrap the context around that
moment to bring clarity so that the
audience understands what you're saying,
and then deliver it in the best possible
way. That is the way to tell a great
story.